all right
it is called pass so i will start so hi
everybody and welcome to my talk eating
humble pie
which is about going from a toy problem
to a real world solution in predicting
customer lifetime value and actually
ties in i realized quite nicely with the
keynotes that we just heard because
this is very much a tale of misery and
woe but also a lot of fun and when i say
misery and woe i mean
um it's the love-hate relationship that
you know we data scientists have with
our crappy data and our crappy models
and things like this and
i say this in a purely positive way that
this is what we are
busy with this is the challenge that
it's fun to
try to overcome and at my company we're
very much in the middle of this mess
and and my talk today will be about this
so who am i
my name is catherine munro i'm a data
scientist and the data science
ambassador for smarter e-commerce or
smac
and we are a company based in austria
where our domain is e-commerce so our
clients are big online retailers who are
running google shopping ads campaigns so
if you've ever
typed something into google and noticed
ads along the top of the search engine
results page the serp our clients are
making those ads and we have different
solutions all data driven and some of
the machine learning driven and so on
that are about optimizing those
campaigns
and that's what we are doing in the team
and in my
free time which is uh using and abusing
this word i'm also a trainer for
linkedin learning i'm a volunteer mentor
for female coders where we teach women
how to code
education lead for women in ai upper
austria and i did also
co-write and edit the data science
handbook
that our wonderful speaker wolf just
told you about so please get that book
we're really proud of it and we hope you
can get some use out of it but enough
shameless self-promotion let's actually
get on with the the topic of the talk
so we're going to cover what is customer
lifetime value and how can you model it
or predict it
and then more importantly how can you do
it right
um we don't actually have the answer for
that yet but we can tell you
some tricks we've learned so far
and then time for conclusion and
questions of course
so customer lifetime value what is it
very very simple it's the value
generated by a customer over their
lifetime with the business so from the
first purchase they ever make to the
last and uh value could be pure revenue
or it might be profit more on that later
now there are sort of two main ways that
you can think about customer lifetime
value and it is best to start simple and
look into the past and just what is my
customer lifetime value so far and
already with that kind of insight you
can do great things you can identify
customer segments and their needs
so
the high customer lifetime value group
why is it that they are generating so
much revenue for you are they just
buying a porsche once or they buying
lots and lots of cheap things very often
and what needs do they have what are you
doing right that's keeping them coming
back to you
because then you can try to keep doing
that and
on the inverse your low value customers
what is it that maybe they don't like
that you could improve on or are they
always buying uh one product kind of
early in their lifetime with you and
then never again maybe that product
really sucks
so um
this is very important you can
understand customer journey so
if you notice your high value customers
are the ones who are signing up in a
physical store and your low value ones
are signing up online what does that
tell you is your website crappy are your
store service people amazing very
important to know
you can look at how demographics like
age and location and things like this
affect customer lifetime value just to
understand your customers better and
serve them better whether these are
services or products it's the same in
the end
you can try to market to those different
groups better because once you
understand them you can speak in the
language they want to hear
a very important point probably should
have put this earlier on
you can know what to spend on customer
acquisition what i mean by that is it's
expensive to get your first customer
and
you want to make sure those customers
are the ones you're retaining and who
are going to then have a long lifetime
with you and spend a lot of money and so
and you also want to know when on
average do you break even with your
customer acquisition spending and can
you try to improve that and get that
time frame down a little bit
and the nice thing about just
calculating historically is then you
have a baseline to improve on so then
you can try out some of these
different things like creating the
different strategies
and then later recalculate your average
clv see how you're going
then if you want to get into the future
cli prediction or estimations we should
really call it
uh uses are things like preventing churn
so you can predict that a customer is
actually
looking like they will never purchase
from you again why how can you re-engage
with them
um on the inverse you can decide which
customers to fire
i would be fired by peeking kloppenberg
in a day if they had this set up because
i buy so much stuff online i try it all
on at home i send it all back and who
pays for the shipping costs they do and
who gets the revenue not them because i
send everything back they would love to
find me and you can find that out with
these kind of uh methods
um
another potential is if you predict that
a customer is maybe sort of somewhat
loyal to you but they're not in your
stella category you're really loyal
ambassadors maybe you can engage them
with some special targeted emails or a
phone call to turn them into ambassadors
so maybe they start to invite their
friends
and on a practical side as well very
important you can try to anticipate
revenue inflows so if you know when
customers are
tend to spend in their overall lifetime
this helps give you a bit of a feeling
for
your your cash flow which is very
important
as a business
so
how can we model uh or predict customer
lifetime value so here we'll go through
some some basically techniques
there you can start with a stupid simple
formula
it's based on three elements and they
make sense
how much does a customer usually buy
how often do they shop with you
and how long is their lifespan
so as an example
if your average customer spends about 25
euro per transaction they shop twice a
month and they stay with you about two
years they're worth 1200 to you on
average so this will be one number for
your whole all of your customers
and you can vary this if you want to get
more sophisticated by actually thinking
about margin instead of just revenue so
if you don't have enough data to know
margin on an individual transaction
level you could make an estimate and
multiply this sum at the end by a margin
factor
or if you do
know the margin on the transactions then
you could use that instead of the
revenue for example
now this is really simple and that's
great because
it makes sense and it's very easy to
implement but that's kind of about it
because it's not very actionable you
have one number for your whole customer
base
so even if you start to try to change
things and improve it and then you
calculate this number again it's going
up or down yeah but why what did i do
right or wrong
um
it also averages out the sales velocity
so you lose track of this you know are
they all spending at the beginning of
their lifetime or over the whole time
you don't know this anymore
and it doesn't help you understand
anything about your customer segments
and another problem is it's not very
reliable so being averaged
it's very easily skewed especially if
you have some big spenders especially if
you have a mixture of retail and
business clients because as business
clients they might buy huge sums and
this completely messes it up
um
another problem in so-called
non-contractual situations is you never
actually know when a customer dies you
don't know when they stop
purchasing from you a contractual
situation is different that's when you
have like a phone contract or something
that you have to actually actively
cancel then you know you've lost them
and uh we have this naive assumption
that spending and churn are constant for
all customers and obviously that's
not true either so how can we improve on
this
cohort analysis
is designed to answer some questions
like on average what's a customer worth
to me after three months or after a year
when do they spend the most during their
lifetime
how are different demographic groups
different in their average clv so maybe
i have some region maybe a fancy part of
the city and they spend more money or
something like this
and
how does the acquisition funnel affect
the clv so that's what i said about did
they sign up in store or online was it
due to a promotion or something so loads
of questions you can do that by simply
applying the average clv formula to
different customer segments
you could segment the customer the
customers sorry buy the acquisition
channel if you wanted to or what's very
common is to segment them by acquisition
month or you could say week if you have
a very
fast sort of shopping rate it depends on
the seasonality of your domain but it's
common to um just basically uh
segment the customers into the month of
their first purchase
this could mean that it's their first
purchase ever or especially at the start
of the data you don't know if they were
already a customer here so you don't
know if it's really when they became a
customer or just they already were but
anyway you segment them like this and
that's what we see along this axis
and then
you apply the formula
to each group and so then on the
on the y-axis here
we have the month since the earliest
transaction and so you can see in this
case that okay customers who um their
first purchase in my data set was in
december they're they're spending a lot
in their first month with me they're
spending really a lot
but even as the months go on they're
still spending and maybe that's because
they just got such great amazing
christmas presents for their family they
fell in love with your store or maybe
probably more likely they were already
customers at the start of this data
collection that's why they're more loyal
they're spending more and customers here
in the middle they sign up in summer why
maybe this is why they're they're not
spending so much so you can already
start to get
some
insights but we still have pros and cons
i mean again it's um it's really easy to
do and you start getting insights
straight away which is great but the
insights are still limited and based on
those naive assumptions so we still want
to get better
so
probably the most famous term you will
find when you start to get into this
topic and google it is rfm approaches
so for each customer you have the
recency which is usually defined as the
age at the last purchase so
the time between their first purchase
and their last purchase that they've
made with you that doesn't mean last is
in they've stopped but just the most
recent one you have in the data
the frequency is the number of repeat
purchases or the number of time periods
where they have made a repeat purchase
and monetary value is it's generally the
average transaction value they're making
and you can do some cool stuff with this
already so you can very very easily
calculate the r f and m score for every
customer
and then you can group them using that
so you could be stupid simple
well stupid's a bad word because it's
still useful but you could say just take
percentiles and say okay i want to
divide my customers into top 20 and then
the next
30 and then the rest or something
or you can apply some unsupervised
clustering
machine learning model like k-means to
try to identify
groups
and once you once you do that
you can
then
discover segments so you can basically
combine these scores and then come up
with something like this where you say
okay when they have um
very high recency
very high frequency very high monetary
value they're obviously awesome but if
for example they have um a high
frequency but they haven't shopped for a
long time then maybe these are customers
that are about to churn and you want to
rescue them so you can already start to
do this or you could
add these features to a machine learning
model which we'll get to
so
again it's got some pros it's it's
intuitive it makes sense
and um
these hand curated groups like on the
previous slide they're very sentient
they have names
store heroes
churn risk new and emerging and that's
easy to give to other departments as
well like your marketing department they
can really do something with that or
even better you should be working with
your marketing department to create
these segments that's why wolf is
absolutely right when he says domain
knowledge is essential i'll also mention
that
um and and so these are really tailored
to your business needs
but there's some cons and this is where
we start to get into the yeah really the
failures that we already made on our our
journey firstly how many levels do you
want to define is it just high medium
and low or
six levels or something depends very
much on the business needs and what the
domain experts tell you they need
and then how to do the scoring um it's
surprisingly common to see just
concatenation of the score so if their
recency value was one out of let's say
one two or three and the frequency is
one and their monetary value is one then
their score is one one one and then you
just draw up a matrix where if it's one
one one they're in this group
and um
uh it's this is used often but it's of
course not weighting these different uh
contributing factors is that appropriate
maybe not
uh especially um recency i think is very
important
because yeah as we said a customer who
used to purchase a lot
but hasn't for a long time probably
their clv to you their future clv is low
unless you do something so it's maybe
bad to lose those the side of the
waiting
another problem is if uh
if you have
uh three potential scores for each you
already get a certain number of
combinations of possible scores and
obviously if you increase that this will
explode to the point where you can't
deal with it anymore
so what you could do instead for example
is just to sum those numbers so you get
fewer groups but now you've lost again
the contribution of those individual
factors
and the hand curation is really nice but
of course time consuming
so
what to do still not onto a perfect
solution yet
uh but now we get some fancy data
science graphs which is what you're all
here for
so we can look at probabilistic models
or the the so-called buy till you die
model
um so it's based on this uh this
principle a customer tosses two coins
buy
or don't so every single day they're
tossing this coin and it has a certain
probability distribution of whether they
will buy or they want to buy and
similarly they're tossing a coin with
again a probability distribution that
you learn which is die
or don't
so
you usually use two kinds of models
most common combination is a so-called
beta geometric negative binomial
distribution for the number of purchases
and the churn factors so you learn those
with one model
and then a so-called gamma gamma model
for the transaction value and then once
you've learned the parameters of those
models super cool because then you can
start making predictions like the future
number of transactions the future value
um and you can also even quite easily
start to adjust for the cost like the
depreciating cost of your stock because
you know something that's sitting in the
warehouse for a long time
it's going to be harder to sell it you
have to sell it for less so you can
adjust for this
and you can calculate the the
probability that a customer is alive and
on this graph okay this is the expected
number of future purchases and so you
can see that a customer the very high
frequency and high recency as in the age
at the last purchase
when both of those are high so they've
been with you a long time and spent
often then the probability of being
alive is very high and of course you get
the inverse in the opposite corner
so that's cool
and
we
have some pros again this is really
famous i'm not sure when these
methods came out but they're really
tried and tested
and despite their simplicity work really
well
and of course we're now in the first
technique that i've talked about where
you can start making predictions into
the future which is what we all like
because it makes us look cool
but it's still not perfect a big problem
is you can't do anything with customers
that have one or maybe two purchases
because the model as you can see here it
doesn't know what to do with them it
just says yet they're alive which is
nonsense maybe they purchased for you
once your website sucked they will never
be back so this is really unfortunate
you can't deal with those kind of
customers
and another problem is the the model
assumptions i'm going to say problem
this is data science we have to you know
make sure our data meets the assumptions
of our models but it can be tricky
especially the gamma gamma model it
assumes no correlation between the
frequency of transactions and the value
and i think that doesn't make sense
because i know that if i forget the shop
one week and have to shop
on like you know every two weeks then my
monetary value will be higher so this
might not this assumption might not be
met for some customers in some domain
sorry some retailers in some domains and
then you can't use this model
and then you can't predict the monetary
value
which is yeah sad
then our product owners are angry with
us
so um what we can do uh is also look at
some machine learning approaches and
we have a couple of options regression
would be to actually predict a number
value for every customer
and the classification would just be to
try to predict the segment are they
going to be a high medium or low value
customer
and
what you tend to do is you have a whole
timeline of of your data and so you set
a threshold date and you calculate these
for example these rfm values uh for this
pre threshold period and then you try to
predict the clv for the post threshold
period so
what you could do is you could just feed
these features and any others you have
into a regression model so when i say
other features you might have
information about um whether they're
purchasing in-store or like in a
physical store or online um what
device they normally use because you
know if you've got a fancy mac or let's
say a fancy laptop or a phone this
implies something about your your
the amount of money you have to spend
and so on
uh or another approach that we've also
done is to cluster the rfm values is
quite common um in this pre uh threshold
period and then you also cluster the
post threshold monetary value so you
basically identify clusters of spenders
in your your test period of data
and and then they become your your
target label so
they're going to end up in this cluster
of monetary value or this or this
and you can again start simple with
percentiles or you could use a
clustering algorithm to discover the
right number of classes like k means and
and then you use those cluster labels as
features for a classification model
so this is cool because again we're able
to predict into the future now we can
add in new features like i said
and
we can use model insights there was
lovely talk about that yesterday catch
it on youtube if you missed it
about using things like shapley values
to
look at the predictions and then
understand okay what made this customer
end up getting a high clv prediction
um obviously you know your marketers ah
they would love to know this
um but the cons and again con is not the
right word um so that the con is that
it's harder to get right because damn
now we have to build a model we have to
get the data right and we have to tune
it and hyperparameter optimize and stuff
that's really not a con because
that's what we're here for that's why we
go to work or at least for me it's fun
um but yeah it's it's
you know it's not as fast or or quick or
simple
so
these are the methods that are uh tend
to be used and are available to you and
that we've doubled with at smac
but what did we learn how can we do it
right
so
um you should get really clear about
your features and methods because
this field tends to be a bit of a
yeah a minefield for um
misleading advice or conflicting advice
or lots of things like that it's not so
clear
so we found that you know for example
frequency um some people will just take
it as a total frequency so for each
customer they calculate that but others
suggest or actually no we had this idea
why don't we divide it by the lifespan
so it's more like okay how many days on
average between a purchase things like
this you could try both but just make
sure that you're clear on it and and of
course if you want to divide it by
lifespan then you have a problem again
with the one-time buyers because their
their frequency will be it'll look like
they make one purchase a day but no they
made one purchase once
monetary value as total or as average so
the
the gamma gamma model
needs this to be average
but the recency frequency monetary
approaches they don't have to have it
this way so you have to be clear of it
because
like one mistake we made is we started
with rfm so we got used to using sum of
monetary value
when we went to check this model
assumption of gamma gamma of course the
transaction frequency was correlated
with the monetary value and there's ah
we can't use this model
turns out no we can we just have to use
the average and then and then the
assumption is fine so have to be really
careful of this
and be aware of the tutorial okay
they're great fun but this is good life
advice in general not just for clv okay
please be careful firstly disregarding
model assumptions so one of the first
two or yeah yeah the first hits you find
when you want to try out rfm approaches
using clustering great tutorial but they
completely abandon the fact that the
k-means clustering algorithm
needs the data to be fairly normally
distributed
and your recency and frequency and
monetary value they're not there like
this they are so skewed
and this this tutorial doesn't mention
it so we you know you just add the log
transformer it's fine but this is really
dangerous when you just
follow these tutorials
another pet peeve is abusing positional
arguments again good life advice in
general
especially for there's a package called
lifetimes it's very very popular for
customer lifetime value predictions and
it many of the methods take these values
or these arguments r
f and m and you see tutorials where they
just put df and then column recently df
column frequency fine
but if you're not paying enough
attention uh and not using like naming
your positional arguments then the
chance of you accidentally putting the
frequency for the recency or vice versa
is really hard to be careful
um
another pet peeve is not explaining
method parameters because then people
just copy the tutorial and they don't
realize what
parameters that they're adding to to
this model so like in the lifetimes
there's a penalizer coeff is one of the
arguments and it's it's applying an l2
penalty to regularize this model to stop
its values being totally crazy huge but
um
you i think as with any data science
project you have to be careful of these
kind of things
and uh profit versus revenue is um
is another
another fun one that we've
been working with
so retailers they want to focus on
profit all right that's a more mature
retailer focuses on profit not just pure
revenue
but this is very hard to do because
there are so many factors that make up
the
uh the cost so
actually this i've written this a little
bit wrong a cost of goods sold is one
factor and this is okay when the
retailer buys the
pair of shoes from the manufacturer how
much does it cost then that's the cost
of goods sold
but there are so many other costs to
getting that product to you so there is
of course the shipping
so it's cost of delivery services
there's cost of payment services which
is uh like the credit card processing
fees
if you return it they have the shipping
cost again but then also they have to
pay somebody to unpack your goods check
that they're not dirty or or something
they might have to steam them to to iron
them again
and then they have to put them back on
the shelf in the warehouse so actually
getting revenue
is
quite a challenge
uh again that's that's fine that's good
it's very interesting to learn these
things but you have to learn them
um oh this is a fun one
so some so we have some friendly
customers we're working with and they
tell us oh yeah
our cost of goods is normally this much
for this unit but if we sell more than
10 000 then it goes down the
manufacturer gives us a discount okay
cool imagine trying to back calculate
that for all the customers who have
bought this product this is really
tricky
so
maybe you can't deal with that but you
should at least be clear and also when
you're communicating with the other
stakeholders outside the data science
team you should be clear on this
i shouldn't need to say this but i will
get good data
and especially i'm so amazed by this but
the the go-to data set that is used in
all of these uh tutorials
i don't want to disrespect it it's it's
um okay so i won't name it but it's
always used and
nice
the problem is uh it's only about one
year of data and a lot of customers have
a longer lifetime so you miss the
seasonality of things like christmas
like are these shoppers only coming once
a year at christmas or or things like
this
um it only has about 500 000 rows and
you have to drop a hundred thousand of
them because they don't have customer id
and uh since you're trying to predict
the value for every individual customer
you need the customer id you can't just
fill that with
the mean or something it doesn't make
sense so it's not huge
um it has a low number of purchases or
at least compared to the clients that we
deal with the amount of conversions per
day is quite low
and
it's very skewed so there because it's a
combination of business and and retail
like regular you and me customers that's
why i warned you about this the the
maximum quantity so the number of units
in a transaction is over 80 000 for one
customer one transaction fun fact they
returned all those items
you can see it in the in the when
there's a negative quantity you know
that they were returned so they
obviously um
yeah blew the budget and had to
had to return it all and the maximum
unit price
is over 38 000 and fine if this was a
store for i don't know
machinery or something that might be
normal but it's not it's a store that
sells
like birthday cards and candles and
things like this but they have you can
look at the descriptions and you see
that there's some descriptions which are
um
uh clearly services and there's one
service that was over 38 000 and this
completely messes up like your
clustering if you want to try to cluster
those rfm scores
this makes it really tricky
by the way i'll just pop in some more
shameless self-promotion so as i said i
do i am a trainer for linkedin learning
and i have a course on predicting
customer lifetime value that's coming
out soon but i am teaching in german but
still you can watch it and pull the
notebooks they're in english
anyway back to the show
beware of different data requirements
for different clv methods so what we're
doing right now at smac is we're trying
to
get a really nice
fixed data set to test multiple models
on to build a good baseline and so on
and unfortunately the different methods
have different requirements so as i told
you the the beat
gamma negative binomial
well i always forget these terms
the bg
bg nbg model it needs customers with one
to two purchases the rfm models don't
but if you want to be able to test the
different methods
fairly on the same data then we just
have to drop all those customers which
is a shame because
you know it's not necessary for those
approaches
um
and
you yeah okay that's what i said here
you have to ensure this consistent data
then as wolf said he's so right get
domain experts
so another fun
situation we've come across is returns
and services
so how do you deal with them okay so
starting with returns
um do you add all these costs like the
return costs and the cleaning costs how
can you calculate them
um and
what about these these services
you have to make it's actually a
business decision do they do these
customers who are buying a lot of
services do they count with the rest of
your customers or do you want to deal
with them separately and
it depends on what your if your client
is a retailer it depends on their
capabilities because they um
might
like if you want to treat these
separately then probably you'll build
two models or something for the
different kinds of customers so it's
more work for you and also for them
they have more work than in handling
those kind of people so
this is a two-way conversation basically
that you have to expect
uh discounts one of our friendly clients
they have loads and loads of discounts
in the transaction so you will see along
with you know you have one row per
product and these rows the product
description is something like 50 off if
you spend more than 100
euro or 5 loyalty discounts or 10 off
your cheapest item
now that's fun
because
what are the costs of these discounts to
your business
versus their incremental value because
yeah you had to sacrifice some profit on
that transaction but maybe that customer
would never have spent that much money
if you hadn't offered it and i mean
we could start a whole separate project
on causality uh modeling to try to
figure that one out but
we're not going to do that yet so for
now what do we do with this the simplest
solution at the moment for us is to drop
it because
um our models
they you know they have a feature about
the number of purchased items and so if
they have this item is included then
they will sort of learn
uh
an average um
like the the average price per item that
these customers are buying is smaller
because actually you've got one extra
item that's contributing zero revenue
and so we really found that um when we
did our first calculations we had all
these customers the the low value
customers we looked at what they were
buying oh well we looked at what all the
segments were buying and we found
the um the the low value customers were
using all the discounts
maybe if they're only bargain hunters
but a lot of these discounts were
loyalty discounts that they only get if
they spend often so we said no this is
this doesn't feel right and this is
and only then did we discover that it
was discounts because of course first we
did explore our data but we didn't i
have to admit we didn't so much look at
the titles because that's huge that's
natural language processing to try and
understand them as a whole new thing so
you have to use your intuition as well
to go wait a minute
this doesn't sit right with us
so and
another fun one
you build an amazing model that's
predicting a value of future customer
lifetime value for every single customer
and the retail says yeah cool but you
know all we can do is maybe make three
or four or five different marketing
strategies so can you like now group
them
sure okay how do we do it maybe you let
the retailers tell you okay we just want
the top five percent and then ten and
then the rest
and then that's really painful because
you know that maybe there are better
clusters better ways you can segment
this data so you could um what you could
do is what we did as well is we so we
took 510 and the rest but then we also
tried like 10 20 and the rest and
different
segmentations like this and then we used
correlation scores to try to see okay
which segmentation then results in uh
the best correlation with this
like the way we have
we have segmented it so
we can we could do this or
we could build a k-means model on top
but then again you have the questions
okay how many clusters you could use say
this elbow method to look at the loss
for each different number of clusters
and decide okay this is probably the
most accurate one
the segment's your data
but the client then says yeah cool but
we only have capacity to have three
segments please make us three segments
so uh yeah it can be an interesting
discussion
um and
lastly get clear about your objectives
so um especially for things like cohort
based approaches where you're just
actually looking in the past
how often do you want to recalculate
those rfm scores is it every time any
customer makes a purchase you
recalculate it for them or is that
unnecessary and you could do it once a
week or once a month or something and a
problem with this is what i call the
shifting threshold problem i'm coining
that term um so
it's nice to do a cohort analysis and
then go okay our high value customers
have on average this recency this
frequency and so on but of course
every time you recalculate this the
averages will change so you won't be
able to get such general insights
um and especially if
you're always expanding your data
so if you start a data collection and
you just keep adding every day to it
this will really change so you could
instead try to make a moving window
which might make your numbers more
stable might not depending on one big
spender or something going on a shopping
spree and also then you're throwing away
data which is sad we're data scientists
we don't like this so that's a problem
it's also important to
educate your clients and also find out
for them what do they need right now do
they need a prediction or can they
already get use out of just those
insights it's in this pyramid of needs
we don't necessarily need to go straight
to the machine learning
um and you know tell your customers that
prediction is it's just our best guess
and then lastly i'm done now
how to use the insights there's so many
ways we can do it so you can just
provide insights which are already
useful to the client
or you can help them to try to optimize
their inventory based on the products
that are bought by the high or low value
customer so get more of the high value
customer products the ones that they
like
[Music]
optimize google shopping ad campaigns to
target high clv
products so you can actually say i want
to spend more money on the products that
are bought by these customers
and so on
so that's really it so i'll just
conclude now by saying uh three points
so clv
is really cool and really sought after
so get amongst it
unfortunately though there are too few
resource resources that discuss
the real world problems that you will
encounter
and the main knowledge in data science
is super important so i'm done now i
will leave my details here so please
feel free to connect with me or on
twitter is where i share a lot of
resources that i find on data science
and so on and i'm ready for your
questions thank you
[Applause]
oh okay i think you're up the first or
yeah
yes thank you and then go up the back in
the yellow thing
thank you for interesting talk and
you know every time i uh approach the
problem of customer lifetime value i
change i faced the challenge uh to
answer the questions what uh lifetime is
actually yes because uh literally a
lifetime is probably not the thing that
we're trying to calculate and uh
sometimes we substitute lifetime with a
charm meaning that we looking for a
frame uh when we lost customer but how
to define this uh
time uh how to define the fact that we
lost the customer
yeah exactly this is uh one of the hard
things in this non-contractual setting
so you know if you're buying on amazon
or something
when will you decide that no screw
amazon and i'm gonna rebel against the
system and never buy from them they have
no way of knowing this all they can do i
guess is uh you know look at your
averages or maybe look at your personal
distribution they see it's really it's
tailing it's tailing it's tailing um
this is this is one of the problems we
don't have an answer for that yet but
you're so this is a good point you can
try um
to use churn instead so churn is one
minus retention rate and retention rate
is your number of um
repeat customers so they've bought more
than once over the whole number of
customers
so you can try things like that it's
cool that you're also working on this
maybe we can talk afterwards but i don't
know the answer this is part of the
problem
sorry that i couldn't i couldn't give
you some tips that you can take back to
your team i wish i could we're still
working on it
no worries off the back
yeah so first of all thanks for the talk
it was really interesting uh i would
like to ask a question concerning the
bgmbd model i know that there is an
extension to that uh which is
uh called which is about the loyal
customer
what sorry
it's about the loyal customer which
basically means that for the higher
amount of purchases or contacts to the
interactions with the with the customer
you get an exponential increase after
some point for example if you obviously
if you are like buying something from
the
one of the biggest retailers like amazon
ebay blah blah
what you will have after certain amount
of purchases
you will forever buy from them i think
there is like a common pattern
among the customers
so um
that's something that i didn't try
because there was a couple of interests
about deploying that and i just was kind
of forced to abandon that project
but did you try that did you try to look
at this loyal customer model when
um
[Music]
yeah i mean
there's a kind of guarantee that the
customer will come back after certain
amount of purchases
no i haven't even heard of it so i'm
gonna be really unsatisfying for you and
i will take that idea to my team but no
i didn't hear of that yet i'm not the
main driver of the of the project i'm
working on basket insights at the moment
which is i should also talk for an hour
about this um
unfortunately no but you can we can
connect and uh and share some ideas uh
in the future and if we do try it and
you're not able to try it i would be
very happy to to talk to you about it
but yeah yep thanks sorry i can't answer
for now oh and one other thing
which is i don't know if this might be
not more of a question but some idea you
said that for the one-two customers
there will be
uh no prediction but if i'm remember
right because there's a prediction but
for the the probability of being alive
it's a hundred percent
which is unreal there is an exponent
there
there's an exponent basically which
means that
yeah first purchase will be like 100
percent but the second one will be like
exponentially low which will be like
0.00 oh yeah i have this what i want to
say is it's uh
it's still a prediction which is
yeah oh yeah that one though no this is
the only gamma gamma one i think this
yeah so basically if i if i said no
prediction then i probably misspoke you
can make predictions but um you know if
you look at this for example
you can see here the predicted
likelihood of being alive is is a
hundred percent
uh if they've only made one purchase and
this sort of
you know you you can't really know that
yet
so
yeah
and the surroundings again uh something
that uh so i looked only on the
probabilistic models i didn't try the k
n n etc
uh uh for the k ns i mean uh as you said
there is an issue with the
uh
distributions being not normal
then maybe there can be used k medics
etc when you are kind of
getting rid of detail
well we we log transformed it and we
found that our data distributions were
then fine and so then we could apply the
the k n it was nice yeah yeah this was
the other yeah it was actually super
satisfying it's one of those really nice
moments when you look and it's just oh
it's so perfect now
but another question here we better move
on
one more question i guess thanks
catherine for the talk i'm interested uh
have you delivered
your solution to production and which
models have you choose no not production
yet we are very much in the stage of
working with their friendly clients um
and and learning so and which models
perform well in europe we
where
we found for example my first models
really really sucked which was just
using random forest and xg boost but
that was on the toy data set or toy but
the classic data set
then the project was taken over by my
colleagues they are getting a better
results with so they're trying they've
tried some automl
so it's basically non-linear regression
they're trying some simple regressions
they're trying x g boost um and some
classification and this is really really
working progress so i don't know yet
we're waiting i will find out on the
next sink where they've gotten with the
newest models but basically we did some
exploratory work and you know i built
some notebooks and things and to get us
into the topic and then i handed this
over on boarded the new people and and
then we said okay now we do the proper
data science of fixing a data set and uh
setting up um sort of a good experiment
platform so we're in that stage right
now again you just have to watch this
space
and i guess that's all we have time for
so thank you thank you very much
i